let's talk about Hollywood and China
because China is making a lot of money
these days they pretty much own
everything they probably own this chair
and everything I'm wearing and
everything you're sitting on right now
and now they've sort of infiltrated
Hollywood and everyone's talking about
how the big Hollywood blockbusters
especially are all being funded by China
and they are putting regulations on the
movies in terms of content because they
don't want to offend the Chinese
audience because they want to get into
that market China only allows 34 foreign
films to be shown annually so if you
want a piece of that money like
transformers 4 which is partly being
shot in China you're gonna do things
that the Chinese government wants you to
do basically I mean this again this is
sort of like the exon story we did
earlier this seems to me just about
money but how dangerous is it that
something as lofty as our film business
here could be infiltrated by the Chinese
Fred well it's a communist country and
they have a lot of control how many kids
you can have and one-fifth of the world
population with the fastest-growing
economy so Hollywood has we do in this
country Scout owing to their demands and
the limited number of films that they're
exposed there but like 10 new screens
are opening a day in China so it's a
huge Virginie market for us and when
there's money there's Hollywood and I
think it's good because we're so limited
in the number of films we can make right
now based on funding that if they will
support some of these films either
financially backing him and also in
going to the movies I think it's great
yeah is there an artistic issue here
though because you know there's already
been examples of let's you know things
that have been produced co-produced by
Chinese companies where they take out
content that maybe the the bad guy is
Chinese and instead they make him
Taiwanese or something like that you
know what I mean and is there so just do
we have an artistic problem when we're
making films that are gonna be backed by
another one sacred thing about Hollywood
blockbusters in the summer is their
artistic integrity yes I think that yeah
if transformers 8 didn't have a Chinese
villain robot
I mean people would just completely lose
it and we would lose that that in-depth
highly honed social commentary that we
find Michael Bay explosion films were
fighting robots I could do a three-hour
show on transformers remember the
scrotum joke in the second one where
giant was like I was in I've been in
countless like Coen brother movies we're
underneath the enemy scrotum and literal
lines to being construct the comedy was
started there is something weird about
this to me because you know even the GI
Joe movie that sequel just came out a
couple months ago
you know GI Joe when we were growing up
was and and when you were younger was
was the real real American hero that's
what he was called GI Joe in the movie
is not a real American hero it's like an
international group of fighters to save
the world you guys don't see any like
odd inherent problem with that that
we're losing some sort of American pride
thing because we're trying to I love it
China is helping our economy immensely
particularly in luxury retail that's
who's buying all this stuff right now
they have their own Facebook Ren Ren and
I guess we bow is their Twitter and we
need to adapt to that the presents can
be meeting with the Chinese premier in
Rancho Mirage this week and I think
that's exciting that we are working
together and we need to take the two
biggest economies and mesh them and
Hollywood is certainly no exception as
long as they don't censor them too much
because I think well we'll lose a lot
but it's important that we work together
with China and get along and hopefully
they'll have a little uprising there and
have a democracy in that country someday
right but how do we stop them from
censoring because they own us first off
and then they're gonna back our films
like how are we gonna stop them hey guys
guys it's just it finds an equilibrium
as well it's gonna happen like and the
best part for China is they don't have
to change at all there's definitely like
I cities in China are far more Western
than people would think they are so yes
there's always pressure coming from the
Sidda fide versions of China to to the
government saying let in more
westernized stuff but I mean the people
who will bend over backwards more than
anyone are the Hollywood studios because
all they want is the bottom line so
they're willing they're actually in
cahoots
my concern is that like how do we find
out who to hate other than we up there
for you you watch the news and that's
just take so much time or like that's
boring yeah so we need to find out
through movies who we hate and if China
isn't a villain because of this how do
we know we're supposed to hate them you
know I agree with your crazy point there
because I was thinking even this week
with this whole Syria thing it's it's
very clear that Russia is on the other
side you know they're backing aside
we're backing the rebels and there is
this thing happening and I tweeted this
but we need like a rocky for you know
what I mean in rocky for you knew
rocky was American Drago was Russian at
what site but I feel like we don't have
anything to sort of take our geopolitics
and bring it into mainstream thinking
maybe grateful I spent my youth in
air-raid shelters but the Soviet Union
was gonna blow us off the world so it's
good that the world's getting along we
don't need bigger holes we there there's
a lot I like canned tuna sorry had a lot
of that no it's the world is is is
functioning right now and it is one
world that's exciting to see and so we
got have enough enemies out there we
still got Iran we got North Korea and
that's that's plenty